oui
ouf nous sommes en direct depuis la
rochelle où se déroule le festival nrj
et océans et nous sommes dans le grand
auditorium de l'espace encan un festival
qui je vous le rappelle s'inscrit dans
le cadre du débat public éoliennes en
mer nouvelle aquitaine et pendant cette
nouvelle table ronde nous avons le
plaisir d'accueillir
trois vidéastes qui vulgarise la science
avec succès sur leur chaîne youtube
respectives et qui à l'occasion de ce
débat public ont accepté de décrypter
les enjeux des énergies marines vous
allez le voir sous différents aspects
d'ailleurs vous sur youtube et vous le
public n'hésitez pas à leur poser vos
questions jean lorraine je vous propose
d'aller dans la salle tendre vos micros
au public alors avec nous thomas durand
de la chaîne youtube la tronche en biais
et rodolphe meyer de la chaîne youtube
le réveil heures et c'est pas tout nous
avons également avec nous en duplex
valentine delattre de la chaîne youtube
sciences de comptoir bonjour ou
valentine tu nous entends
bonjour je me sens très bien et même si
on entend très bien donc c'est super on
vous remercie tous les trois d'être avec
nous pour répondre à cette grande
question comment
vulgariser l'énergie c'est parti
[Musique]
eh
bien voilà les amis merci d'être avec
nous bassine invités c'est ma grande
spécialité d'énergie
conférence de deux heures très du tout
alors là c'est vrai que c'est pas ta
spécialité
thomas par contre tu peux t'appuyer sur
rodolphe est ce que les vidéos de 50
minutes et sur l'énergie il en produit
l'an produits va nous raconter comment
il va nous raconter vous allez nous
raconter ensemble d'ailleurs comment
vous travaillez ce serait pas mal quand
même de commencer par se présenter
thomas durand la ligne éditoriale de ta
chaine la tronche-en-biais sa vocation
cette chaîne c'est quoi ils viennent
nous nous aimons la pensée critique
l'esprit critique et donc on est une
équipe on est en une asso et on essaye
de se demander avec les gens
comment est-ce qu'on peut essayer de
penser moins mal de repères et nos
billets et de se rendre compte quand un
truc qu'on pensait savoir vote ne savait
pas on croyait et puisse corriger en
fait l'éloge de l'erreur de la
correction ouais c'est ça les loges de
l'erreur même quand elle est pas beau
long terme ça va mais les fêtes news ben
là c'est alors celle là c'est de la
faute c'est de la manipulation il y en a
aussi et ce sont nos ennemis ne nous
aiment pas et on lui nous menons les
aime parce que nous on est les gentils
d'accord alors vous traitez aussi de la
zététique qu'est la zététique c'est un
mot quand même il faudrait rappeler un
petit peu ce que c'est tu es chez que
j'en sais ton boulot c'est bon c'est son
boulot si tu veux te remets les avants
dolf tu peux donc à cette éthique c'est
du second degré kettane qui cherche qui
examine et 17h et le goût du jour il ya
30 ans par an libre aucun professeur de
physique à 1 nice et donc c'est l'art du
doute ouais donc ces scientifiques 1
revue alors de la science la science et
la science et l'éthique c'est plus du
militantisme de dollars pour la raison
ouais et dire il ya plein de questions
de la vie de tous les jours qui pourrait
être un peu exploré un peu on pourrait
avoir moins de présence bête si on
appliquait un peu de méthode qu'on
emprunte la dation en tout c'est pas
votre nation c'était les stations se
fait dans des conditions particulières
mais c'est le renier soit la science
pour apprendre des choses pour moi être
moins bête d'accord pourquoi le pourquoi
la tronche-en-biais
parce que j'ai des coups j'ai découvert
enfin pas moi si j'ai vu que des gens
travaillent sur les biais cognitifs
illumina super intéressant ça on à la
tronche candelier voilà et donc avec des
aides et loki quand on a cherché à
rompre la chaîne on a failli s'appeler
les mâles biaisé
non non c'est un ordi peut-être pas
faire ça parce qu'on peut rappaz être
invité par fred est non non non non ça
ça passe pas notamment dans les
émissions pour les rifains c'est
absolument impossible tu perds toute une
partie de son auditoire la des
cofondateurs également de l'association
pour la science et la transmission de
l'esprit critique ça existe cette
association la steak last et oui ça
existe depuis six ans maintenant voilà
je suis directeur de l'astag donc ont un
peu de respect s'il te plaît allez
on est à petit et on est à nancy et et
le projet principal de la sec c'est la
chaîne pour l'instant d'accord rodolphe
rodolphe meyer pourquoi la chaîne
s'appelle le réveil heures c'est pour
nous réveiller aussi un peu les
c'est un peu l'idée au début mais
c'était aussi un peu ma naïveté en fait
moi j'ai vraiment pris conscience des
grands problèmes environnementaux à la
toute fin de mes études est vraiment par
le champ universitaire quoi par les
papiers scientifiques les alertes qu'on
entend de plus en plus sur le climat la
biodiversité etc et c'est ce qui m'a
convaincu qu'il fallait faire quelque
chose et à l'époque je me suis dis bah
voilà vu que ces éléments passer encore
assez mal dans le grand public je
pensais encore un peu le cas sur
certains sujets je me suis dit je vais
amener ces éléments et tout le monde va
se rendre compte que c'est un problème
donc voilà j'imaginais qu'il suffisait
de présenter des éléments pour
convaincre et donc le réveil heures
c'est un peu l'idée mais c'est un peu
naïf a été plus compliqué quand même
quelle formation toi quel cursus
scientifique par mois j'ai fait une
grande école d'ingénieurs et laquelle je
me suis levé ce pci qui ne volent sur
paris et
et qui est une école à ces généralistes
et j'ai fait une dernière année en
erasmus en prenant un peu mes cours dans
des dans un master de sciences
environnementales et c'est vraiment là
que je me suis rendu compte qu'il y
avait un problème et du cou à l'époque
je me suis dit ma manière de participer
à essayer de résoudre ces grand problème
c'est de faire un doctorat dans les
sciences de l'environnement et donc j'ai
fait un doctorat et j'ai commencé ma
chaîne en parallèle de mon doctorat et
maintenant cette chaîne c'est mon
activité principale et j'arrive à en
vivre et donc je continue de parler de
problèmes environnementaux et d'énergie
après problèmes environnementaux j'ai
surtout parler de climat et d'énergie
parce que c'est très lié au climat la
façon dont on produit on consomme on
utilise de l'énergie dans notre société
aujourd'hui d'accord le journalisme je
sais pas si on peut dire où
l'information c'est une forme de
sciences en tout cas tu as quand même un
petit peu abandonné la voie de la
recherche mais en même temps tu fais
encore de la recherche justement pour
faire tes vidéos mais j'avais envie de
faire de la médiation scientifique ouais
en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que vu
qu enfin quand je me suis rendu compte
qu'on avait ses problèmes
environnementaux je me suis dirigé vers
un doctorat et ensuite j'ai continué à
creuser je me suis rendu compte que dans
le champ scientifique on connaissait
très bien le changement climatique on
savait qu'elles étaient les conséquences
quelles étaient les causes on savait
même ce qu'il fallait faire en gros
réduire notre consommation de ressources
fossiles et ça même ces éléments un peu
basique
c'était assez mal compris du grand
public et des politiques et de la
société en général et du coup j'ai
décidé de faire de la médiation en
parallèle et après je me suis dirigé
vers ce terrain là parce que c'est là
que j'ai l'impression d'être plus utile
plus jeter mais après je poserai
vraiment pas les deux on a besoin de
plus de journalistes qui se forme à la
science pour discuter de ces enjeux on a
besoin aussi de plus de scientifiques
qui décident de vulgariser sur ces
questions évidemment ce n'est pas une
obligation parce que vulgariser ça veut
dire aller au contact du public il ya
des contraintes il ya des rapports des
fois un peu conflictuelles tout le monde
n'est pas fait pour ça mais en tout cas
je pense que il ya largement la place
sur les enjeux énergie climat pour avoir
plus de journalistes plus de
vulgarisateur là dessus on en a besoin
lui réclame des concurrents je réclame
des concurrents beau je venais et bien
venez détruire mon yahiaoui il ya un
aspect un petit peu un côté un petit peu
militant dans ta trajectoire
ouais le contenu qui présente c'est
vraiment les éléments scientifiques mais
derrière l'idée derrière ses jeux phares
de la chaîne de l' envie de créer la
chaîne il ya un peu une volonté d'un
pacte oui c'est que je pense que ces
enjeux sont graves qu'on n'en prend pas
la mesure que les actions sont pas
proportionnés et j'essaye de présenter
des éléments pour pousser dans la bonne
direction donc il ya vraiment eu une
idée de voilà il ya des choses qu'on
doit faire on doit modifier la société
sur certains aspects et du coup j'essaye
d'apporter ma pierre à cet édifice donc
de ce point de vue c'est un projet un
peu politique oui d'accord
thomas toi on l'a pas précisé mais
formation scientifique également docteur
en biologie ouais et c'était très bien
j'aime beaucoup la recherche mais les
éoliennes se prend vraiment pas je
connais pas grand chose mais disons que
je sais me poser des question j'ai
appris ça la science m'a aidé à
apprendre à poser la question
c'est déjà se poser les bonnes questions
c'est 60% du travail ou moins ouais donc
je suis pas en retard que ça voilà qu'à
30 % qui restent et pour les réponses
n'utilisez pas que tu as aidé à être
curieux aussi oui la curiosité n'est pas
un vilain dévoue il faut arrêter de dire
ça l'indiscrétion mais la curiosité est
une grande qualité très bien on va
rejoindre valentine tu es avec nous
voulons tine toujours toujours ça va
bien ça va très bien merci alors
sciences de comptoir tiens on va
continuer pourquoi sur le comptoir
comment t'es venue l'idée de monter
cette chaîne est pourquoi
s'appelle-t-elle comme ça a alors
pourquoi j'ai eu l'idée de monter de
cette chaîne parce que c'était la mode
des youtuber scientifique ça commençait
à arriver et que et que je me suis dit
que c'est un média intéressant et que je
connaissais pas du tout mais je me suis
dit allez je vais me lancer là dedans
parce que j'avais déjà un blog je
faisais déjà d'autres activités de
vulgarisation à côté et donc ça c'était
trop cool et pourquoi sciences de
comptoir parce que figure toi que
j'étais en train de lire quand j'ai
ouvert le blog qui s'appelait comme ça
les brèves de comptoir de jean marie
gourio et c'était mon livre de chevet et
du coup je me suis dit voilà je veux
raconter des brèves de sciences un peu
et sur un ton décalé et du coup sciences
de comptoir quel est d'après vous quelle
est ta formation à toi
alors j'ai une formation géologie en
biologie niveau master et en journalisme
scientifique
d'accord blaise énergies renouvelables
c'est parce que tu traite en priorité
sur ta chaîne
absolument pas d'habitude je parle de
cailloux donc comment les chais un
caillou comment se forme le sable qu'y
at-il à l'intérieur de la terre et comme
on le sait voilà donc un peu loin des
éoliennes mais j'ai été amené à amiens
degrés c et j'ai appris plein de choses
j'ai la même question portent les 3
monts va commencer par toi justement
valentine pourquoi tu as accepté dans le
cadre de ce débat public doit relever le
défi de décrypter justement les énergies
marines et toi notamment à travers sa
rejoint quand même un petit peu plus
d'informations sans doute à travers la
question de des risques pour la
biodiversité c'est ça tout à fait pas
pour l'argent vient de vidéos
ça vous fait ça pour l'argent
oui mais il est tellement chose qu'on
fait et il n'est pas payé pour défaire
en effet quand même là il faut qu on
était un peu payé déjà les autres
peut-être non plus
sérieusement sérieusement valentine
oui c'était une blague évidemment donc
oui c'est vous parce qu'en fait comme
j'ai une formation en d'écologie là le
point de nos diversités impact
fondamental ça ça ouais est certes sujet
j'avais absolument pas eu le même
creuset parce que c'était comme ça et
donc de vie et patti l'occasion et puis
un peu le côté les énergies
renouvelables du coup
et que le calme
d'accord merci on vient vers toi tout de
suite et vous pourquoi vous avez accepté
de relever ce défi bah moi depuis deux
ans et des brouettes je pense parce je
parle beaucoup d'énergie sur la chaîne
donc j'ai fait différentes filières j'ai
fait le photovoltaïque j'ai fait
l'éolien terrestre j'avais pas encore
parlé de l'éolien en mer donc quand on
m'a demandé j'ai accepté déjà parce que
c'est une vidéo que j'aurais fait de
tout mais est en fait l'éolien en mer on
en parle de plus en plus en france avec
la montée en puissance de tout ça et
j'avais été assez étonné de voir dans
les rapports de rte là qui sont sortis
à la fin de l'an dernier avec point
l'éolien en mer devenait important en
france parce que pour l'instant on en a
zéro et ça va être amené à être une part
15 20 25 % ça répond à des scénarios
mais ça va être amené à une part non
négligeable de la production en 2050 et
donc pour donner un peu débile parce que
forcément ça va soulever des questions
et pour moi-même me renseigner sur ces
sujets et et voilà les c'est vraiment
intéressant les oignons alors pour ceux
qui ne te connaissent pas encore il faut
préciser quand même que sur la chaîne
n'aurait d'ailleurs rodolphe fait des
vidéos longue d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant on pourra en parler parce
qu'en général on dit toujours sur
youtube ou sur les réseaux sociaux pour
faire du court non non c'est long alors
je peux vous garantir que ces fouilles
et c'est on va loin alors cette la
vulgarisation des fois c'est de la
vulgarisation si j'ose dire quand même
de haut niveau c'est ça les formats en
général que tu fais c'est 50 minutes
ouais ouais c'est c'est au tour de 50
minutes je les fais pour que ce soit
regardable par quelqu'un qui n'a pas de
notion faut pas avoir tout le
vocabulaire après ça demande un peu
d'attention un forcément vu que c'est
des moments qui sont un peu long mais si
quelqu'un se concentrent il peut
comprendre ce que je raconte normalement
c'est fait pour ça tu le fais aussi de
façon à ce que ça soit découpé
aujourd'hui youtube ces chapitres et de
deux chapitres et donc vous pouvez très
bien regarder juste le bout qui vous
intéresse ou regardez en plusieurs fois
ça je vous laisse gérer et après je
pense qu'il ya un public pour ce contenu
d'ailleurs la preuve c'est que cette
chaîne elle fonctionne et aujourd'hui
elle fonctionne quasiment
essentiellement grâce au financement
participatif d'accord une partie du
public qui me soutient directement à
broc ça veut dire que au moins pour une
partie du flic sas a une valeur et à
près de 2 ma part en fait c'est vraiment
un positionnement volontaire c'est moi
avec ce que je sais faire je peux faire
ce contenu un peu fouillé j'ai le temps
d'aller chercher dans la littérature
scientifique
j'ai un peu l'habitude d'aller là dedans
et du coup je peux prendre le temps par
rapport à des journalistes qui vont
moins avoir le temps de reprendre un
sujet donc je peux vraiment aller au
fond des choses et après je pense qu'on
est dans un écosystème où je veux bien
croire qu'il ya une forme de
ruissellement j'y crois pas du tout en
économisant la théorie du ruissellement
à bord mais quand on parle de
vulgarisation derrière il peut y avoir
des personnes qui viennent vers moi et
dire bah moi je veux parler de ce sujet
mais je vais être beaucoup plus court
est ce que tu peux relire
ce que je fais et ça peut s'appuyer sur
mes vidéos donc je pense que la
vulgarisation il ya différents publics
il ya différents niveaux de
vulgarisation et ce positionnement on
peut en discuter on peut dire tu ferais
mieux de faire des vidéos de 20 minutes
mais en tout cas pour l'instant c'est un
positionnement volontaire de ma part on
en a parlé tout à l'heure et toi t'en as
pourquoi tu t'es lancé là justement
qu'est ce qui t'a intéressé dans
pourquoi tu a relevé le défi et moi on
m'a proposé parce que c'était un de neuf
de faire un débat est donc animer le
débat donc c'est ce qu'on a fait ce
matin à 10h30 sur hbo diversité et
éolien moi j'ai aucune expertise je vais
pas venir faire un court il faudrait que
je passe un temps fou acquérir ce que
lui a déjà acquis moi je sais poser des
questions est un peu piquant donc du
coup même si je veux le matisse mais
parce que ça m'intéresse en terme
d'enjeu citoyens c'est quand même
fondamental comment on va avoir des
navires dans 30 ans parce que si on en
reste là où on est maintenant on a leur
a plu et donc voilà le comme je milite
pour qu'une culture du débat en france
qu'on n'a pas vraiment puisqu'il va
venir et participer et animer un débat
moi ça mais ça m'intéresse du coup oui
mais d'abord bien faire ça et j'ai dit
oui abbas et bien voilà bien relevé on
va prendre tout de suite des questions
du public
gens
alors c'est plutôt une question qu'on a
reçues sur le chat youtube c'est ça
concerne davantage le format donc le
format vidéo est de savoir si vous vous
fixer des limites de durée ou quelque
sorte de limite voilà est-ce que vous
pouvez nous parler de ce les mains de ce
format est ce que ça vous contraint ou
au contraire est-ce que ça vous facilite
la tâche
ok je te remercie on va répondre à cette
question genre je vois des mains qui se
lèvent vous pouvez aussi appeler on va
on va aller vers vous alors le format
c'est très variable le format idéal
n'existe pas ça dépend des politiques
que nous qu'on va voir nous sur la
tranche en mai ont fait des bonds reçoit
des scientifiques
pour les interviews de deux heures bon
c'est long deux heures d'intérêt soit
c'est bien aussi d'avoir la liberté sur
un média donne pas
avoir de limite finalement d éviter que
ses intérêts sont contents ils sous
entendent développer il n'y a pas la
publicité il n'ya pas les guignols de
l'info et passe d'un citoyen mêlée mais
ça va pas couper que pas par moi je
comprends la parole mais en dehors de ça
et de médias ghosn est de temps en temps
ils ont le temps de développer un truc
on peut revenir après le public on avoir
du temps de parole scientifique c'est un
truc qu'on n'a pas sur les grands médias
il faudrait peut-être une chaîne de
télévision où les gens aient le temps de
dire ça mais on se fait une idée un jour
ou l'autre
le format rodolphe parce que c'est vrai
on le disait tout à l'heure tu es vidéos
elles sont longues mais elle son
chapitre est malgré tout well son
chapitre et après il faut se rendre
compte qu'une vidéo qui va durer une
heure j'ai passé une centaine d'heures à
la creuse et donc vous gagnez quand même
deux ordres de grandeurs quoi quand vous
regardez ça et après effectivement il ya
des vidéos où ça m'arrive en rédigeant
un script de dégager au fur et à mesure
des questions qui finalement sont
peut-être moins importante parce qu'elle
pourrait durer plus d'une heure je vous
le garantis et après les contraintes du
format en fait les contraintes du format
ce n'est pas tant la durée il ya deux
contraintes qui sont à mon avis
importante c'est premièrement que la
vidéo ça prend du temps à faire plus
qu'à écrire et il ya un deuxième
problème quand on fait de la
vulgarisation sous ce format c'est que
on peut pas modifier une vidéo après
qu'elle soit publiée et demain c'est un
énorme désavantage par rapport à un
texte 1 go si je me plante sur une
implication une phrase de travers je
peux l'éviter après coup et donc ça
c'est moi je passe beaucoup de temps à
relire à cogiter pas mal pour limiter
les erreurs mais ça reste un gros
problème c'est qu'on a moins le tu
publies une vidéo environ toutes les
cinq semaines ouais par là et pas tout à
fait une par mois donc donc gros travail
valentine répond son format tu fais plus
court parfois quand même oui je sais
plus court parce qu'en fait je me mets à
la place du viewer sein du spectateur et
comme j'ai des petits problèmes
d'attention je regarde pas les vidéos
qui font plus d'une demi heure donc
j'essaye de me limiter à 20 25 minutes
ça veut dire que l'organisme
on note merci aux lentilles nous on a
compris la formation marchait sous un
tunnel je ne vous entends pas
donc je donc toi tu préfère faire un
petit peu plus court tu penses que c'est
c'est plus facile pour le public de
suivre une vidéo un petit peu plus
courte je préfère et d'autre part j'ai
un montage qui me prend beaucoup de
temps parce que j'essaye de faire des
effets spéciaux nul pour faire des
blagues et des choses comme ça et donc
il ya tout un tout un travail de montage
qui me prend beaucoup beaucoup de temps
à la minute et je peux passer très bien
une 2010 menée à faire un effet surcroît
seconde vidéo où j'explique mon visage
qui sort de ma tête ce genre de choses
tu fais ton oui je fais tout est du coup
plus la vie des mois de longues plus je
passe le temps de montage et de rouge
quand tu sors une vidéo tous les combien
à peu près à la question qui là j'essaye
de partir sur une base de tous les mois
a pu de moi de voir si
belle phase aller on a une autre
question je crois pour vous qui nous
vient de la salle cette fois ci
effectivement alors là on a abordé un
peu les questions de fort mahon va
aborder les questions de fond je suis
avec sylvain sylvain à une question à
poser à newburgh oui bonjour
déjà juste je voulais vous remercier
fred parce que je suis un enfant de
c'est pas sorcier et si je suis devenu
scientifique c'est grâce ou à cause de
vous je sais par péter hill et des
conseils de saïx régulièrement dans le
ring comme je l'appelle à merci non
merci beaucoup et l'a coincé parce qu'on
commence à passais la conception des
enfants c'est pas sorcier
alors question est donc donc je vois que
le message passe chez les enfants et que
je vois son utilité il l'a maintenant je
suis un adulte comment vous faites pour
faire passer des messages percutants aux
adultes parce que le format est
différent et surtout dans ce contexte je
trouve de fatigue intellectuelle
généralisé ou moi aujourd'hui aucune
idée un prime dans mon cerveau car je
pense que j'ai trop donné qu'ils
arrivent vers man donc je voudrais
savoir est-ce que vous adapter à sa
comment vous faites pour faire passer un
message percutant
alors comment faire et puis c'est vrai
qu'il ya dans l'offre oui bah le ccc
l'info d'amy on est où l'obésité savez
vous faut visiter infobésité merci
beaucoup c'est des mots valises je suis
là mesdames était là pour ça ça vient
d'un tutu mais au cas où je commençais
trop vieux maintenant et
en gros il faut être il faut avoir le le
bon format pour intéresser des gens et
donc valentina rigolote non ça ça marche
bien il très sérieuse marche bien et
nous parce qu'on fait mais j'ai pas la
réponse est qu'il ya sans doute des
études de marché pour voir comment on
fait je ne connais pas moi je ne sais
pas comment mais je n'ai pas fait
d'études de marché dont on fait ce qu'on
a envie de faire en disant tiens ça
serait bien que ça existe on veut le
faire et on ne s'est pas posé ces
questions là je suis pas sûr que les
collègues mais je m'intéresse mais je
pense je pense qu'à des approches très
différentes déjà c'est compliqué parce
qu'au final les personnes qui vont nous
regarder c'est celle qui choisissent de
nous regarder si vous avez un public
fidèle bah c'est même un sait déjà
comment on arrive à les atteindre mais
bien vrai je pense qu'on est des
approches très différentes et moi la
proche de la chaîne c'est quand même de
prendre le temps d'expliquer de
démontrer quelque part de montrer des
éléments scientifiques à l'image et donc
effectivement ça prend du temps mais ça
veut dire aussi que quand il ya des
informations contradictoires en face si
elles sont pas démontrés de la même
manière normalement elles ne sont pas
mises au même plan c'est un peu ça si je
montre qu'elle est le calcul pour
expliquer qu'une voiture électrique et
mais moins au final qu'une voiture
thermique si je monte le calcul les
différentes étapes oui ça m est plus à
la production mai - usage contre à ce
qu'on dit voilà on prend telle qu'ils
durée de vie en kilomètres donc on fait
toutes les hypothèses en fait le
résultat est beaucoup plus convaincant
donc c'est aussi pour ça que cette
longueur a fait une vraie démonstration
bas en fin juillet tu es sûr beaucoup de
vidéos oui j'essaye de montrer les
éléments et c'est pour ça que cette
longueur et une importance c'est que
certes ça prend plus de temps mais si
c'est une démonstration si c'est quelque
chose enfin des éléments probants des
où je monte mes sources etc ça reste
aussi plus que ces cités en cinq minutes
et après la personne entend cinq minutes
qui répond linverse et elle est un peu
perdu donc moi c'est quelque part c'est
un peu la stratégie de la chaîne c'est
d'aller au fond des choses pour avoir
une information qui reste qui est qui
est pertinente et du coup en espérant
que ça permet de lutter un peu contre
montre tout ce qu'on peut entendre par
ailleurs et là il ya un truc que je
pourrai un peu développés c'est que dans
un premier temps sur le climat notamment
j'ai présenté les éléments scientifiques
qui étaient disponibles parce que c'est
comme ça que moi j'ai été convaincu et
dans un second temps je me suis rendu
compte que le public sur youtube par
exemple était quand même exposé à des
conférences climato-sceptiques et moi je
regardais ses conférences thématiques
sceptique je pense j'ai lu plus de
contenu climato sceptiques que des
scientifiques parce que ça m'intéressait
vraiment de comprendre de comprendre
quelles étaient les arguments et en fait
moi quand je vois ça et que j'ai
beaucoup bossé le climat je vois où l
arnaque et je peux aller vérifier
l'information mais c'est pas dans le
tout le monde n'est pas capable de faire
ça parce qu'il n'a pas le temps parce
qu'il n'a pas l'habitude de la
littérature scientifique etc et dans un
second temps quand je parlais du climat
sur la chaîne j'ai été prendre ces
conférences limmat aux sceptiques je les
ai décortiqué je les ai critique et j'ai
mis des éléments en face parce que je
suis passé d'un mode on présente tous
les éléments et c'est le public qui fait
le tri qui est encore le mode
journalistique de base je pense
aujourd'hui on a un vide des gens à
charge et à décharge on laisse le public
faire le tri sauf que sur des enjeux
techniques scientifiques complexes le
public n'est pas toujours capable de
faire le tri dans un second temps j'ai
apporté des réponses à des arguments à
des idées erronées qui étaient là dans
le donc là encore c'est une des bonnes
que et et je pense que vous le faites un
peu sur la tronche en biais sa de
devenir aussi critiqué ce qu'il ya en
face parce que tout le monde n'a pas le
temps on n'a pas la méthode pour pour
s'y retrouver idéalement il faudrait que
les gens acquièrent la méthode mais
apprend le temps comme on fait
valentine à cette question justement de
jusqu où mettre le curseur sur la
difficulté par exemple du propos à qui
s'adressait plutôt enfant plutôt plus
âgés les deux peut-être parfois comment
tu fais
en fait ce qui est bien c'est de définir
davance son public cible donc par
exemple une personne donc
personnellement c'est ma fille qui est
entre collèges lycées et d'essayer de
vulgariser quelque chose comme si je lui
racontais l'information donc ça permet
d'adapter pour double exciter les
différents quais ce genre de choses et
puis après comme je suis moi même
soumise à ce côté là l'enfant qui
ressort par l'autre et du coup je pense
que la forme a beau coup à jouer
là-dedans la fin de la vidéo c'est pour
ça que c'est avec avec soin des petits
petite respiration de temps en temps
soit au contraire un montage plus qui
adopte pour un peu tout le monde et puis
si je veux avec l'émotion sur le côté
bas à partir du moment où on met nos sûr
avec une information est la plus
tendance à être nourris des donc perso
j'ai une émotion céleri je ne sais pas
faire autre chose donc et il yad'autres
ça très bien le ruban
mais nous à la colère sous les yeux
ça va
on va prendre une autre question sur
youtube
question lorraine c'est une question de
quand un tueur dans les commentaires
youtube il se demande entre autres
comment on gère le sponsoring d'une
vidéo et comment garder une liberté
éditoriale une éthique éditorial c'est
une excellente question
surtout sur youtube alors je sais
rodolphe toi tu te fais un point
d'honneur à dire même dans la vie
d'ailleurs dans la vidéo que tu as fait
sur l'éolien offshore tu le dis au début
et à la fin j'ai travaillé c'est une
commande de la commission mais je les
fais parce que d'abord on m'a donné
carte blanche mais je tiens à vous dire
quand même que j'ai été rémunérée donc
il ya une authenticité c'est important
d'être honnête ouais en fait c'est la
première vidéo est pour l'instant la
seule pour laquelle j'ai été rémunérée
sur la chaîne donc j'ai régulièrement
des propositions
et je refuse et je refuse la majorité et
c'est même pas tant parce que ça affecte
le contenu parce que là j'ai eu carte
blanche en fait c'est le cas de beaucoup
de partenariats qu'on peut faire c'est
plus pour des problèmes de perception en
fait quand on est rémunéré le public
perçoit pas la vidéo de la même manière
à tous seul gène n a quasiment tous
refusé donc là effectivement j'ai été
rémunérée et je les ai bien dit et on a
eu complètement cartes blanches
et n'empêche qu'il ya quand même des
remarques dans une partie du public ça
on peut pas l'empêcher et du coup c'est
compliqué je pense qu'il faut vraiment
le dire et après et après l'essentiel du
temps je refuse pour être complètement
libre et là j'ai accepté parce que
normalement cette commission nationale
du débat public c'est une institution
neutre qui a pour vocation d'informer le
public donc c'est quasiment la mission
que je me donne il n'y a pas deux il n'y
a pas de commande il n'y a pas de
conflit là dessus on a le même but le
même intérêt s'il m'avait dit en lisant
ce truc là et bien sûr faut pas le dire
parce que c'est faux on a juré accepté
parce que je veux pas dire un truc faut
donc comment on allait même but c'était
je pense du point de vue de ma
communauté c'est un des rares sponsors
que je peux accepter qu'on d'accord donc
financement le rappel essentiellement
par la communauté et puis une fois temps
j'entends comme on peut dire des piges
comme on dit dans notre jargon par
exemple tu as fait une vidéo avec le
journal le monde ouais j'ai fait une
vidéo avec le journal le monde qui donc
qui est sur leur chaîne qui étaient
rémunérés ça m'arrive de faire un peu de
conférences je donne l'exemple 1-0 round
informel et il ya quelques oui non mais
c'est ça ça y'a pas de soucis il n'y a
pas de souci là-dessus et sinon
essentiellement je pense 80 90 % des
revenus c'est le financement
participatif point d'accorder une chance
bien si tu fais un truc avant lui que ça
dit avec le mot m'arrive je peux été
payés thomas j'ai fait un truc avec lui
- dumont va payer je les rappelle elle
était sur le l'effet que sur la mode la
lune etc c'est un porte-conteneurs
approche anti non mais favorable et je
ne fais avoir du coup jamais aucune
publicité n'a été sponsorisé sur la
chaîne à part du coup quand on les red
effrayés pour se déplacer pour des
choses qui n'ont rien dit et et à chaque
fois le contrat c est ce que vous vous
êtes un as de traiter le sujet ont dit
oui et c'est tout après on on des
brouillages avait une influence sur le
contenu et la l'idée c'était de venir
pour animer une table ronde vers l'avant
j'ai discuté avec lise marie qui gère
dire
qu'elle travaille pour trouver les
intervalles ans évidemment la table
ronde elle dépend les intervenants donc
si un moment donné bon je suis manipulé
et qu'on met en face de moi des gens qui
sont pas du tout les bonnes personnes et
je suis passé éveillé pour m'en rendre
compte je me fais avoir peut-être ce qui
s'est passé mais maintenant c'est à vous
travaillez d'être sceptique sur qui est
là pourquoi mais bon je suis assez
confiant et la tranche en vielle du
comment belle et des noms des noms aussi
les tons on est on est une asso et le
moi je suis alors c'est quoi on connaît
tous un petit pee wee un beauty patronne
manque un
quant à elle aux assauts pour soutenir
le la times je suis salariée de la sono
seul truc qui me paye et il ya beaucoup
de pastels dès qu on a quelques uns de
leurs cadets face à nous
l'argent arrive toujours dans des trucs
mais quelques moments où vous financez
vous les youtube mais c'est pas moi qui
les posent la question du bien mais je
viens de youtube au passage est vrai
c'est valentine sur cette question ce
genre de questions oui
ok bah comment on fait justement pour
essayer de garder l'indépendance et puis
face aux questions de de financement
d'éventuels sponsors
d'accord alors qu des sponsors il ya
deux choses qui existent sur youtube
c'est le sponsoring et des partenariats
vous me dites je dis des bêtises
le plan de ce ring dans grosse année
plus on fait les cons inclus dans le
coût qui n'a pas forcément rapport aux
éditoriaux de notre vidéo exemple pour
un vpn et d'autre part il ya les
partenariats ou là pour le coup une
vidéo compilant l'occurrence pour les
éoliennes sur l'estonienne demandé par
le débat public et de l'ena break 7 2
choses différentes
de le sponsoring fonctions avec une
boîte qui correspondra à l'honneur avec
vous mais je ne vois pas spécialement en
plein pendant tout ça marche avec côté
éditorial vidéo les partenariats c'est
plus délicat effectivement
je refuse
c'est d'ailleurs donc comme rodolphe
sachant que effectivement pourquoi le
partenariat des halles c'est ce qui
s'est exactement passé justement avec le
public c'est une donne un budget il nous
donne un sujet et ils nous mettent des
ressources à disposition par oui mais il
n'interfère vraiment pas avec le contenu
des vidéos avec ça il nous impose rien
n'est ni d'intervenir
un message à faire passer ce genre de
choses vraiment on fait notre travail
donc pour moi ça c'est le principal
moyen at on enfin je me base sur une
équipe comme abyss type puisque je suis
journaliste scientifique à base et du
coup je n'accepterai pas de faire une
vidéo
qui ne correspondent pas à l'éthique que
j'ai quoi
merci pour vos précisions on est une
autre question dans la salle jean je
crois effectivement je suis avec hugo
qui a 11 ans et qui a une question sur
le public ciblé est-ce que vous faisait
vous faites des vidéos pour les enfants
et sinon est-ce que vous conseillerez
déchaînent
alors malheureusement c'est la cible que
moi je ne sais pas faire voilà je sais
pourquoi vous oubliez les enfants c'est
pas qu'on oublie c'est que je pense que
c'est des enfants sont tellement
importants qu'il vaut mieux faire ça
bien moi qui le fais ça je m'occupe des
sceaux revient au culte des adultes yeux
vont presque mort alors c'est moins
grave ces mêmes conséquences non mais
c'est un pli particulier parce que là
sur les sujets qu'on traite sur les
croyances au taux plein de choses c'est
quand même souvent un petit peu fou un
peu polémique etc et si vous voulez
parler de croyance à des enfants c'est
plus délicat
que de parler de sujets de sciences
anton telecom nous on est quand même sur
un sur un registre qui est pas
uniquement parler de science mais parler
de comment la situation a nécessité
comme relation se construit c'est un peu
mais ça là comment la science se
construisent justement il faut en parler
le plus tôt possible sans doute et il
faut la démarche scientifique a fait il
faut l'expliquer c'est peut-être pas
toujours facile mais on peut l'expliquer
aux plus jeunes il faut forer le faire
oui bon alors pour ego et on va le faire
un jour
hugo rodolphe
moi je le fais pas non plus parce qu'en
fait je fais les vidéos quelque part que
j'aimerais voir sur les questions que je
me pose est devancée des questions qui
sont un peu complexe et ensuite il
réussit un problème de forme c'est que
moi je sais pas trop faire du beau
montage comme valentine je ne sais pas
dessiner donc je pense qu'il ya aussi
une question de forme quand on s'adresse
à un public qui est plus jeune et en
fait je suis pas capable de faire ça
capable tu sais pas peut-être
et peut-être ça m'a permis à moins que
de faire des trucs plus compliqué face
qu'à moi je suis très attaché au fond en
fait je fais wii ou moins de foot et les
enfants aiment le font aussi des choses
les accords d'accord et je reviens à ce
que je disais tout à l'heure je pense
que c'est un écosystème où il peut y
avoir du ruissellement et peut y avoir
des personnes qui font un contenu plus
adapté aux enfants en en en se basant
sur ce qu'ils ont appris dans ma vidéo
et pour l'anecdote j'avais relu un petit
livre pour enfants je crois que c'est
même pour trois quatre ans sur l'effet
de serre qui avait été fait par
quelqu'un qui dessinent ça et qui m'a
dit voilà je veux pas dire de bêtises un
enfant et et j'ai relu pour le fond et
lui il a fait un petit livre avec des
beaux petits dessins sur l'effet de
serre la couette de la planète ça
s'appelait donc on voyait des petites
plumes sortir du pot d'échappement des
voitures et tous alimentés c'était très
joli c'était très bien et sur le fond
c'étaient les bonnes idées qui passait
moi je serais pas capable de parler un
enfant aussi bien mais je peux dire
voilà avec mes vidéos il a vu le
changement climatique il a compris
comment ça fonctionnait et lui il sait
porter cette parole au delà on peut pas
tout faire c'est un problème c'est un
problème de temps mais je pense que
l'esprit sorcier s'adresse un peu plus à
un public plus jeune ya plus de dix ans
maintenant c'est pas sorcier le faisais
qui s'est passé c'est vrai que sur
youtube sinon l'esprit essentielle le
fait nettement moins effectivement sais
c'est pas tout à fait le même le même
travail valentine tu t'adresses aux
enfants parfois
alors ça m'arrive directement sur ma
chaîne même si en général c'est des
vidéos qui permettra aux familles à la
condition d'avoir un esprit assez
les blagues qui sont un peu mais à côté
de ça je fais des petites vidéos pour un
site qui s'adresse plus aux adolescents
qu'aux enfants que c'est à partir de 10
ans je crois qu'ils s'appellent un
fourgon et qui s'appelait avant un jour
une question est donc à des petites des
petites vidéos comme ça sur
luminati enfin différentes que
mais surtout à la bad la chaîne s'était
un jour une question
mes dessins animés en fait avec
quelqu'un qui a expliqué sur plein de
sujets différents qui s'adresse aux
enfants je t'invite à aller jeter un
oeil à l'achat il ya plein de choses
très intéressantes ils sont en plus très
bien dessiné sinon effectivement thème
du doigt sur une niche vacante comme on
dit qui la légalisation pour enfants et
sur youtube donc ça c'est dommage vous
avez
non excusez-moi hugo d'isabelle quand
vous avez des conseils à me donner ou
des six tomes donné je ne sais pas alors
un petit conseil juste donc la chaîne
info mythos est un bon début je pense et
puis après sinon si c'est pas en vidéo
mais il ya des bonnes réactions dessus
si tu aimes il ya un blog qui s'appelle
kimi science pays tian ce qui explique
plein de sujets scientifiques aux
enfants très simplement il ya des
petites expériences petit chocolat
hockey est tout pour moi merci pour tes
conseils hugo prend des notes j'ai vu
c'est bien hugo prend des notes c'est
bon parfait gens on a une autre
agression ouais on a une nouvelle
question dans le public je suis avec
martin qui a 22 ans et qui a une
question sur la thématique qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui alors maintenant
martin je te laisse poser la question
alors oui aujourd'hui l'énergie c'est un
sujet où beaucoup de gens sont hyper
positionner notamment du côté
politiciens avec beaucoup de pro
nucléaire antinucléaires pour voitures
électriques anti voitures électriques et
je me demandais si c'était difficile
d'arriver derrière avec une neutralité
de scientifiques d'en face à des gens
qui sont hyper positionner
excellente question maraka il faut
aborder ça parce que là c'est vrai on
est sur un sujet extrêmement toujours
sensible alors messieurs qu'en pensez
vous et bah c'est la question du thème
c'est la polarisation des gens qui ont
un avis avant de regarder s'ils veulent
le regardez donc on a les premiers clair
qu'ils vont pas aimer les contenus en
tilt qui vont pas les voir ap on a les
ans puis ceux qui aiment qu'ils vont
coûts qui vont équivalent est partagé et
qui a parlé de neutralité et ça c'est un
petit peu une illusion personne n'est
neutre je suis pas une autre soit à
peine de mort je ne suis pas neutre sur
les résultats de est ce que le climat
change ou pages pas l'autre je prends
position par les sciences donc
on a l'illusion comme ça que des gens
pourraient arriver être parfaitement
neutre mort aucun lien avec personne et
dire le vrai
et peut-être que c'est con vraiment
raison c'est que ceux qui sont vachement
pas neutre très engagé pour un truc qui
tape tellement vrai et comment on
distingue et ben il n'y a pas de moyen
facile et donc il faut voir qui
argumente le mieux donc il faut comparer
et donc il faut regarder les autres et
on n'a pas envie
ouais je vais rebondir sur ce que disait
thomas effectivement c'est pas parce que
il ya une polarisation importante que la
science va se retrouver au milieu sur
les questions de climat si on va
chercher les éléments scientifiques
clairement aujourd'hui ils sont pas du
côté des climato-sceptiques et on peut
se polariser très nettement sur cette
question le changement climatique est là
il est d'origine humaine il est
important et ça on peut le dire en étant
objectif donc ce que j'entends par
objectif c'est en considérant les
éléments scientifiques disponibles et
donc moi effectivement c'est ce que
j'essaye de faire d'aller regarder ces
éléments scientifiques disponibles
d'essayer de les digérer et de les
régurgiter désolé pour l'image et de
rendre ça accessible et après faut
réussir à le faire
en allant au delà de ces préjugés quoi
suspendre son jugement le temps d'aller
dans tout ça ce qui limite ce qui limite
mes erreurs ou mais positionnement
sait aussi que j'essaie de faire relire
mes scripts par des gens papa par des
personnes que j'essaye d'avoir j'essaye
d'avoir des opinions différentes dans
mes lecteurs de chez edf par exemple ça
c'est plus
certaines aides toi même a été un peu
comment on peut dire entre guillemets
victimes puisque aujourd'hui sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est comme ça on est
pas mal attaqué ont honte à reprocher à
un moment donné où on a soupçonné de
pouvoir être pro nucléaire alors il ya
un problème déjà excellent
on en est au point de polarisation dans
le débat où on désigne par pro-nucléaire
quelqu'un qui n'est pas anti donc il ya
déjà un problème si je n'ai pas une
position dogmatique de refus absolu
nucléaire je suis pro nucléaire alors
que pendant un pro-nucléaire cinétique
est qu'il faudrait mettre à quelqu'un
qui a une position dogmatique absolu sur
nucléaire mais la plupart des pro
nucléaires aujourd'hui disent que c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut envisager parmi
d'autres parce que les éléments poussent
dans cette direction moi j'ai pas du
tout un
amour particulier sur le nucléaire si le
nucléaire est plus chère à plus d'impact
dans mémento et plus risquées etc on
dégage si on peut s'en passer c'est pas
ça le problème et du coup j'essaye de me
positionner quand je fais des vidéos sur
le nucléaire effectivement on me le
reproche j'ai des commentaires pas
gentil gmail pas gentil j'ai messages
vocaux pas gentil d'anti nucléaires
quand je fais la même chose sur l'éolien
en mer j'ai le droit la même chose des
anti éoliens et quand j'ai fait saute
l'image et les premiers que j'eus les
climato-sceptiques
17 juin ce qu'on disait martin on est
quand même sur un terrain et sur un
sujet aujourd'hui extrêmement son style
c'est sûr c'est sûr et le positionnement
de la chaîne ça a toujours été d'essayer
de prendre les éléments scientifiques de
se faire une opinion et de les présenter
et j'ai l'impression et j'espère
vraiment de tout mon coeur que c'est le
cas j'ai l'impression que c'est une
chaîne ou des personnes avec une
polarisation différentes arrive à
regarder et peuvent changer d'avis je
sais qu'il ya des personnes en regardant
ma chaîne qui ont changé la vie sur
nucléaire qui ont changé d'avis sur
l'éolien qui ont changé la vie sur le
climat qui ont changé la vie sur les
voitures électriques et c'est le plus
beau cadeau qu'on peut me faire s'il ya
des gens avec des opinions diversifié
qui continuent d'arriver à regarder ce
contenu quoi et toi est-ce que tu as
changé d'avis en travaillant au sujet on
découvre en un seul coup que oui ils
pouvaient toi même avoir quelques idées
reçues ah oui oui j'aimerais vraiment en
fait sur quasiment tous les sujets que
je regarde je vais changer d'opinion sur
certaines sous question et il ya des
sujets où j'ai beaucoup changé d'opinion
en regardant
est ce que je peux donner comme heures
en faisant les vidéos sur la voiture
électrique je pensais que ça sera un
débat qu'il y aurait des choses à peser
le pour et le contre et où je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le bilan est beaucoup
plus nette que je le pensais et depuis
plus longtemps j'ai l'impression que
j'ai fait ma vidéo art comme le match
est déjà finie donc c'est donc le
résultat c'est quoi il faut plus de
votes alors ce qu'il ya de mieux c'est
aujourd'hui on a une consommation
d'énergie qui est énorme les transports
c'est énorme en consommation d'énergie
donc faut réussir à réduire ça on est
d'accord un plus de transports en commun
moins d'avions moins de voitures ça
serait bien ça prend plein de place dans
l'espace public etc dont 4,1 pour et la
rochelle l'accord donc ça c'est déjà
faut pas oublier ce point là d'abord on
essaye de contraindre un peu la
consommation si la question se pose
voiture électrique qu'on de voitures
thermiques sur une utilisation qui va
monter ça va dépendre de la durée de vie
en fait comme la boucherie trick un peu
plus impactées à la production si on va
sur cent cinquante mille deux cent mille
kilomètres une voiture électrique c'est
facilement deux tiers de moins
d'émissions donc c'est quand même c'est
quand même un impact qui est pas
négligeable après ça va soulever plein
de ces questions allez voir les vidéos
aller voir les vidéos on en aura une
autre tout à l'heure on va reprendre une
question dans le public oh là là j'ai le
plaisir d'apercevoir dans le public
d'ailleurs notre ami jérôme bonaldi mme
chan bhl qui est à côté de ses biens
géromin je suis là en tant que vieux
envie de te voir aurait pu être votre
père j'aurais bien aimé votre père
moi j'ai travaillé à l'époque à
l'ancêtre d'internet cet appel à la
télévision mais la donne a changé et
c'est à vous que je vous parle d' avec
vos responsabilités la donne a changé
par rapport à ce que je faisais il ya 40
ans pas au siècle dernier c'est que il
ya la défiance maintenant défiance on
n'y croit plus je ne crois plus aux
politiques je ne crois plus à la
religion je crois plus à l'armée je
crois plus aux journaux et pire encore
je ne crois pas aux scientifiques on l'a
vu avec le co vide ça veut dire qu'il
faut que vous sachiez que des gens déjà
il faut
il faut combattre al a priori négatifs
que vous à quelques pas mal de gens vont
avoir de plus en plus en vous regardant
la deuxième chose c'est que je pense
qu'il faut que vous soyez proactif c'est
à dire que vous avez un public qui vous
a choisi il faut aller sur youtube c'est
une démarche volontaire de ma part mais
tous ceux qui ne vont pas qu'ils ne font
pas de cette démarche il faut aller les
chercher ça veut dire peut-être un peu
plus tôt un peu marketing et je voyais
là aujourd'hui dans les débats sur
l'énergie au sénat sur les nerfs les
gens étaient plutôt ans en réaction en
retrait et pas assez pas assez punchy
passé push voilà je vous dire que vous
avez du boulot et qu'on compte sur vous
moi je suis à la retraite
bon courage et travaillez travaillez
bien je vous en prie c'est vachement
important encore plus qu'aujourd'hui
parce que avec la défiance il ya je suis
très heureux placer ce mot là il ya
beaucoup de l'ultra crépy l'arianisme
oui
adjugé mot compte triple merci beaucoup
jérôme on peut applaudir aussi voir
toutes les émissions et les plaisirs que
tu nous as apporté
et continue quand même contenu
et donc il a une ouvre sa chaîne youtube
quand le collège il va ouvrir sa chaîne
youtube
retraités
on a enfin on a conscience je pense de
ce format de résistance en face surtout
par rapport à la zététique où on est
actif parce qu'on se rend compte qu'il
ya une défiance vis-à-vis de la parole
scientifique
malgré tout quand on regarde un peu à
qui les gens font confiance les
scientifiques restent les numéros 1 avec
les médecins si les deux mêmes après le
big bang enfin je crois on verra bien si
ça aussi ça résiste mais ça c'est rod il
ya parce qu'il ya une défiance des
élites et qui prend les décisions sur
l'énergie c'est les élites et si c'est
pas transparent mais vraiment
transparent alors les gens auront des
méfiance justifiée ou en tout cas
justifiable et donc il faut plus de
transparence et nous mêmes notre niveau
on ne peut pas forcer des pouvoirs être
transparents on peut un peu plus
critiques un petit peu
mais on a conscience du problème en
effet matin est ce qu'on est à la
hauteur je ne sais pas tu pensais que
[Musique]
je pense pas l'important pour lutter
contre cette défiance c'est surtout
d'expliquer comment en produit ses
connaissances comment fonctionne la
science pour quoi des fois on change
d'avis pourquoi y ait des ratés pourquoi
ça évolue continuellement et un peu ce
qu'on comment on doit croire ce qu on
doit croire quoi donc ça c'est plus mon
travail je te laisse et moi je le fais
un peu sur l'énergie est sûre sur le
climat sur les problèmes
environnementaux en présentant jus du
coup les éléments scientifiques qui
permettent de prendre ces positions l'a
donc en expliquant ces cas derrière en
disant pas forcément voilà faut croire
ça moi j'ai une heure donc je peux
expliquer pourquoi on considère que le
nucléaire l'éolien le photovoltaïque
émettent peu de co2 voilà parce qu'on va
dire oui mais faut quand même les
construire ok on prend en compte la
construction on regarde que ça fait on
prend en compte les transports et on
voit qu'effectivement le bilan est
faible
encore une fois je reviens il ya ce cet
aspect pédagogique de démontrer plutôt
que juste dire faut croire mais
peut-être mais en attend trop souvent de
la science ou des médiateurs
scientifiques qu'ils nous apportent des
réponses toutes faites alors que les
réponses sont pas aussi simple que ça on
l'a vu dans le débat qui précédait
d'ailleurs sur cette question il a quand
même des scientifiques ou des groupes
d'experts qui vont travailler pour
savoir si en 2050 on pourrait
consommer uniquement des énergies
renouvelables certains nous disent oui
d'autres nous disent non c'est un rêve
et oui mais nous en tant que grand
public en face on est forcément un peu
perdu 1 alors nez on se dit ils ne
savent pas non je vais rebondir je vais
rebondir tout de suite déjà c'était un
peu dommage que le débat tombe si vite
sur nucléaire renouvelable comme souvent
faut pas oublier que quand même les deux
tiers de notre consommation d'énergie en
france ça reste le pétrole le gaz
naturel un tout petit peu le charbon et
c'est ça le gros problème c'est ça le
gros problème aujourd'hui on perd
beaucoup de temps à se faire affronter
deux technologies
ensuite là on est sur une question
particulière qui est celle des modèles
des projections dans tous les cas on va
avoir des hypothèses qui sont assez
structurante de coûts de développement
technologique qui n'existe pas encore et
même ce que vous avez vous avez un peu
parlé des scénarios de rte moi moi
vraiment ce qui est frappant quand je
lis le rapport si le plus important je
pense c'est que il ya différents
scénarios avec plus ou moins nucléaire
est quelque part l'élément le plus
important pour moi pour trancher c'est
il ya des risques qui sont associés à
chacune des deux trajectoires
normalement un scientifique cd sérieux
quand il fait des modèles comme ça il
dit pas on va y arriver il dit il ya une
certaine probité qu'on y arrive voilà
les difficultés qu'il faut surmonter et
en fait c'est à ce qu'il dit parfois les
journalistes non un petit peu ça dépend
vraiment de quelques acteurs on parle ça
dépend vraiment de quel acteur en parle
et en fait quand on regarde la rte par
exemple il dit un truc qui est assez
simple et qui est assez logique je pense
c'est la neutralité carbone en 2050
c'est extrêmement difficile on va pas se
le cacher je pense que la scientifique
du giec a été clair là dessus on est
quand même mal barré pour y arriver à
chaque fois qu'on se refuse une
technologie on rend ce chantier un peu
plus difficile on a un chantier dont
tout le monde quasiment sous-estiment la
difficulté si on commence ce chantier en
jetant la moitié de la boîte à outils à
la poubelle on n'est pas sortis
donc c'est vraiment une notion de risque
de fiabilité de probabilités de que
c'est jose à dien quoi d'accord on
avance justement sur ce que vous avez pu
apprendre ou non en travaillant sur les
ailes et les éoliennes en mer puisque
c'est le sujet sur lequel vous avez
travaillé valentine tu étais davantage
sur l'aspect
impact sur l'environnement impact sur la
biodiversité qu'est ce que tu as appris
et comment on pourrait résumer la vidéo
je rappelle qu'on peut aller la voir à
les publier d'ores et déjà sur ton site
alors qu'est ce que tu as pu apprendre
j'ai pu apprendre pas mal de trucs y
avait beaucoup beaucoup d'impact
extrêmement différent auquel je n'avais
même pas pensé jean tout bêtement le
fait de mettre des socles d'éoliennes
sur le fond marin en fait un mode eefje
la distribution d'équipements donc
potentiellement le
seul qui peut mais bon ça s'éduque les
pays islamiques les effets les plus
importants des éoliennes maire de
l'implantation d'un parc éolien en mer
c'est d'une part le bruit lors du lieu
chantier
parce que le français
julien marin tout ça de cassation comme
hobby et ça peut causer une licence que
vendre sous rapidement long terme un
bestiau amara de ce point de vue là
ça
je pense que oui le risque de comédiens
amplement et qu'il soit c'est quelque
chose mais j'étais surprise côté positif
avait été montrée au parc et un pare
brise et fait une rixe
notamment
amel et
donc les effet posé
comme il ya dix neuvième comment ça
limite les activités william amazon
notamment
du coup ben c'est un peu comme un
sanctuaire jeudi les poissons mais
c'est surtout on écoute et l'autre
d'autres partenaires éducatifs à dire
que les quelques dizaines si tu es
récifs artificiels et du coup ça a créé
une paire roger y
avoir des petits pots chez 10 h x 100 m
haies plantées aussi en gros c'est
encore ça
la biodiversité et la biomasse marine
depuis les eaux je ferme à 1 et aux
oiseaux aussi voter les poissons tu
m'avais pris un goût d'accord en résumé
tu m'as et préciser quand même que je
n'ai pas forcément évident de trouver
aujourd'hui des études scientifiques et
que ça dépend énormément des sites sur
lesquels on va travailler parce qu'on
imagine que la faune évidemment n'est
n'est pas la même en tout cas je renvoie
vers ta vidéo dont le son est nettement
meilleur qu'actuellement parce que là
c'est un petit peu perturbé mon va on va
revenir vers quoi je crois qu'on a une
autre question sur youtube qui est posée
lorraine et oui oui tout à fait nous
avons une question de nicolas giraud et
vous demande selon vous qu'est ce qui
fait que la notion d'énergie et si durs
pour beaucoup à comprendre et il va même
un peu plus loin dans les précisions il
vous demande qu'est ce qui fait d'elle
un pilier récurrent des pseudosciences
que du coup les énergies quand vous
allez voir un chaman un énergéticien ou
un ou un passeur du tout les îles vous
passez ces mains qui ont des taux
vibratoire supérieure avec des bots vis
et
débarrasse de thé douleur c'est grâce
aux énergies le mot énergie quand il
n'est pas associé à des sciences
physiques où est votre mental chimie il
a plus aucun sens sauf qu'il a une
connotation énergie
on regarde ce que cette énergie et en
fait non parce que l'énergie c'est quoi
ça la capacité à modifier la matière des
termes que moi et donc c'est passé c'est
un potentiel ont été modifiés la la la
la matière mais ça fera dire que mes
mains ont d'énergie 20 bien et donc bon
et comme personne n'apprend à l'école ça
quelques mots circulent et qu'il n'y a
pas de définition facile pour nrj et
bien éliminé le mont respecte qu'est ce
que ça veut dire le monde nature
le mot démocratie les compliquer un mot
liberté c'est quoi les gens qui
manifestent dehors actuellement tous les
samedis en bas de chez moi qui font
beaucoup de bruit d'ailleurs c'est comme
pour les halls et c'était beaucoup trop
brusques quand ça s'installe il crée
liberté on a pas de liberté ils sont
librement dans la rue en train de
circuler ils disent qu a pas de liberté
dont on n'a pas le même sens pour le mot
qu'ils ont peut-être raison mais il ya
eu du mal à comprendre ce qu'ils disent
donc on ne s'interroge pas assez sur le
sens des mots et je me tais
je pense qu énergie même pour un
physicien c'est une notion quand même
assez difficile à
saisir à définir et si on le définit
comme notre capacité à changer le monde
c'est logique que s'ils veulent changer
un état il fasse appel à l'énergie il ya
une certaine cohérence avec la notion et
après dans le débat public il faudrait
le définir et en fait qui manquent même
plus c'est de le quantifier de se rendre
compte voilà nous on a besoin d'énergie
pour se chauffer pour s'éclairer pour
internet pour se déplacer et ça fait
vite un mix tout ça et même dans ce
qu'on a entendu aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que le problème de
l'énergie c'est internet et les panneaux
publicitaires problème de l'énergie
aujourd'hui c'est de chauffer les gens
déjà ça c'est des contenus qui sont
énormes c'est de déplacer les gens et
puis l'électricité effectivement mais
mais quand on regarde vraiment la
quantité d'énergie qui est consommé en
france le transport et le chauffage
c'est les quantités qui sont énormes par
rapport à internet ou les panneaux
publicitaires donc les enjeux si on veut
réduire l'utilisation de ressources
fossiles c'est les transports demain
matin c'est pas réfléchir alors fort et
la collection les tricks parce qu'on
veut électrifier mai mais les gros par
le biais des éoliennes on est amené à
parler davantage du mix électrique
de façon globale les ennemis les
maîtrisons effectivement alors non mais
ça n'exclut pas cette question aux mix
électrique pour une raison qui est très
simple c'est quand dans beaucoup de
scénarios aujourd'hui de transition
énergétique dans le monde et en france
également le cas pour réduire la
dépendance au des transports par exemple
aux fossiles on veut électrifier on veut
la voiture eric pour réduire la
dépendance de la production de chaleur
au gaz on veut mettre des pompes à
chaleur ou des radiateurs donc ça amène
à réfléchir aussi à l'électricité
électricité c'est pas qu'une petite
partie enfin ça va être une plus grande
partie l'énergie qu'on consomme demain
mais aujourd'hui quand on pense à
l'énergie qu'on consomme il ya beaucoup
de personnes qui vont rapidement fin
comment dire qu'ils vont qui vont se
diriger vers des usages qui sont pas les
plus importants en termes d'énergie est
ce qui manque dans le débat public c'est
peut-être d'avoir des quantification de
voilà où est l'énergie et l'énergie
aujourd'hui c'est pas que électricité
c'est beaucoup chauffer et se déplacer
d'accord on arrive vers la fin de
l'émission je voulais te poser la
question aussi rodolphe comme je vais
poser à valentine tout à l'heure en
faisant ton enquête sur l'éolien
offshore quand tu connaissais pas
spécialement avant est ce qu'il ya des
choses qui ont pu te surprendre que tu
as découvert qui finalement sur lesquels
tu pouvais mais éventuellement avoir
quelques idées reçues qu'est ce que tu
peux en retenir ou toi tu as fait une
approche beaucoup plus enfin c'est très
chapitré mais il ya une approche un peu
économique et une approche technique et
une approche technologique pas trop
biodiversité ça tu de la laisser là je
les laissais la valentine qui s'en est
très bien chargé alors effectivement
évidemment j'apprends des choses
ensemble et recherche sinon j'aurais pas
besoin de potasser le truc pendant une
centaine d'heures il suffirait je
m'assois et que je raconte et se raconte
ce qui se passe à l'écran
je pense que sur les coûts par exemple
il ya un truc qui est intéressant et qui
est souvent mal compris c'est que une
éolienne en sortie par car l'éolien en
mer c'est moins vrai parce que c'est un
peu cher mais ne vienne terrestre en
sortie de parc ça peut coûter moins cher
que du nouveau nucléaire mais si on
commence à en avoir beaucoup il faut en
face mettre des moyens de stockage
renforcer le réseau est ce qui fait que
ce qui nous intéresse nous c'est pas le
coup en sortie de parc c'est le coup en
sortie de prises électriques chez nous
ils ont entre les deux fours ajouté le
stockage etc mais derrière la calculer
tout ça t'arrive à trouver les données
pour cas alors c'est une bonne question
est là heureusement qu'il y avait ces
scénarios de rte où il ya des cas où il
ya beaucoup de replats d'auteuil en à
moi et du coup qui arrivent à des
conclusions sur l'économie est en fait
qui compte sur le coup c'est quand on
prend en compte les moyens de stockage
etc
donc là c'est bien il y avait des
données sur un sujet où il ya beaucoup
moins de données et où j'ai vraiment
beaucoup galéré c'est la question des
matériaux c'est étonnant mais c'est
compliqué de savoir qui composent ça va
ouais oppose ça va parce que c'est pas
très compliqué mais d'avoir des
quantification et surtout quand on
commence à plonger en littérature il ya
des complications qui sont très
variables pour des problèmes aussi
qu'ils sont liés au monde de la
recherche c'est que quand un article va
sortir en 2020 ça va être sur des
données 2016 qu'ils ont pompé un d'un
article de 2012 et on peut vite commenté
dans le temps comme ça et ce qui se
retrouve que on sort il ya un article
qui sort aujourd'hui qui a des
complications qui sont dépassés depuis
15 ans et quelque part même les
constructeurs aujourd'hui aurait un
intérêt à communiquer sur ce qui a dans
leur zone parce que cette question des
matériaux elle revient de plus en plus
souvent et moi ça me pose un petit
problème c'est pour ça que j'essaie de
quantifier c'est que on a d'un côté
effectivement ses moyens renouvelables
qu'on construit qui ont besoin d'acier
qui ont besoin de cuivre qui ont besoin
d'un peu de terres rares pour les
éoliennes en mer mais faut pas oublier
que on essaye de mettre ça pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone pour
sortir des ressources fossiles par
exemple pétrole dans la mobilité il faut
pas oublier que ça c'est des volumes qui
sont énormes les comptes c'est pour ça
que le sujet complexe de comparer les
choses pas évident
c'est pas évident mais je pense que
cette comparaison faut la faire faut pas
juste regarder quel est l'impact
derrière l'éolien faut regarder quel est
l'impact par rapport aux alternatives ou
alors on parle des impacts d'aller au
lien pour questionner la consommation et
une fois qu'on se dit moi je veux me
chauffer de temps faut encore produire
ça et là faut comparer et il ya beaucoup
de personnes qui ne compare pas qu'ils
monde et si on regarde les impacts
derrière l'éolien il y en aura toujours
derrière le nucléaire il y en aura
toujours des râles photo ld qui n'aura
l'énergie propre ça n'existe pas donc en
fait si à chaque fois on critique une
techno en regardant les inconvénients on
va pas s'en sortir donc on se fixe un
niveau de consommation et ensuite on se
dit voilà comment on optimise sa quels
sont les impacts qu'on accepte qu est-ce
qu on essaye de réduire au maximum et
donc là ça suppose de comparer et pour
ça sur les matériaux il manque beaucoup
d'informations et j'ai pas mal galéré à
avoir des trucs cohérent et fiable quoi
et à la fin on se retrouve avec une
vidéo dans lequel tu as un chapitre où
tu tues tu arrives à peser exactement
combien d'aluminium pour un mégawatt
heure j'essaie de tenir de grandeur de
production c'est étonnant les amis on
arrive vers
fin de cette émission telle intarissable
sur d'ailleurs dans la salle si vous
voulez rencontrer nos amis youtuber il
n'y a pas de problème pour valentine ça
va être un petit peu plus compliqué on
arrive vers la fin qu'est ce que tu nous
réserve comme prochaine vidéo valentine
alors la prochaine vidéo sur ma chaîne
va parler de la forme de la terre qui
n'est ni ronde ni plate ok d'accord et
on rappelle le titre de la vidéo qui a
fait le coup tu as réalisé sur sûr
les éoliennes offshore
je l'échangé 20 fois ça doit être un
truc comme éoliennes en mer un mariage
heureux ou malheureux comme ça
d'accord merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nos rodolphe la prochaine vidéo qui
sortira dans combien cinq semaines bonne
question je sais pas j'en ai une
relativement courte savait faire 25
minutes sur l'inertie climatique donc
voilà vingt-cinq minutes j'ai ce qui se
passe et on arrête les émissions est ce
que le climat se stabilise vite moins
vite je la regarderai celle là du coup
[Rires]
thomas est pas venu c'est le 23 on fait
un live sur la biodynamie la bulle inami
n'est pas forcément ce que vous croyez
le dérive de l'entrepôt aux filles qui
est un petit peu un mouvement peut être
sectaire est un mot forme mais j'ai
quand même le prononcer et le 1er mars
je fais un débat sur dieu avec l'un des
deux auteurs du vol air récemment vol
grand écart d'accord parfait merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous merci
valentine mais c'est thomas merci
rodolphe on vous retrouve bientôt sur
vos chaînes hi-fi ou ben acide de les
applaudir pour ce passionnant débat mais
ses amis et nous on se retrouve bientôt
sur la chaîne l'esprit sorcier ciao
[Musique]